this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I wish I had your little drinky poo a
little drink you're dehydrated man I do
too I want to give a shout out to my
Ontario people a lot of them come up to
me and they go you're a lot taller than
I thought
I say that's good I think you're tiny I
stand next to a giant yeah and probably
because I have short legs and a long
tour so here's the thing
how's that drive to Ontario not too
didn't you tell me I don't know I made
it there in an hour and 15. every night
and a half yeah it's coming from because
you're coming from Manhattan I don't
know man I do a voice cut through like
this yes maybe why it's 60 miles away
because I have to do the 101 that 101.
nasty I don't touch it that's why yeah
because when you told me you got through
that festive that's crazy I still left a
lot of time and I'm like man I'm like
wait a minute it's gonna take me what
now because the great at one point it
said it was gonna take me two hours and
28 minutes and then I checked again
during rush hour and it was like this is
going to take you an hour and 24 minutes
it's weird or two hours and then it
ended up taking me an hour and a half
interesting yes
um interesting that's right we're going
to uh Austin this weekend I got cap
cities Thursday Friday Saturday yes we
are I will see you Friday I only get
there to Friday beautiful so I'll see
you Friday and Saturday let's have some
fun are you how much I want have we we
should call Rogan after this because
you're gonna be how long on the
companion because your show's at what
time I think my shows and cap cities are
probably 7 30 and I don't know because
the I think the main card starts at
eight uh central time yeah so eight
o'clock so no um Saturday
seven and ten so you definitely missed
that yeah I'll be uh start but yeah
um yeah I can't see my face so even even
if we did uh I mean if we start at I
mean yeah we'd have to start five you're
not making a companion I don't think I
am no I thought there was a prelim thing
it was starting at four but we're gonna
all have dinner I think yeah we're
having dinner but four I don't want to
be from I'm not no we're gonna have
dinner at six yeah so I'll join you guys
for dindin and then we'll go but even
you can't do a campaign for a fight
night do the early prelims from watch
you guys uh why don't you guys get the
command and come watch me yeah I'll get
you good seats
cap cities
um I might be able to make your 10
o'clock show I like it see we'll see how
long the campaign because Kim uh we'll
see see what you can do the companion
goes from eight to ten ish you start at
10 I will see we'll see see what happens
but I'll be there Friday buddy good
buddy looking forward to it I'm excited
do you since you're Ontario did you get
a chance of watching the fights I did
watch the fights and uh which I watched
I watched um I watched the gaichi
Poirier fight
um because they had it on a in the
sports bar in the mall in Ontario so I
saw that that was the only UFC fight I
saw and boy oh boy
um I want to get your take on that we
will get in the Crawford Spence did you
get to watch Spence Crawford or just
highlight I did I watched the whole
fight would you watch it I actually
watched it twice I got the pay-per-view
and I watched it when you got home yeah
because I was
I I just couldn't believe uh I know I I
talked to a couple of really great
boxers who were in that camp and other
guys who fought you know on a high level
and they were like I don't know it's a
toss-up it's a toss-up it's a toss-up
number yeah no and uh they then just you
know my feeling is that
uh I don't know what those car accidents
and that detached well that's what we
were talking about outside I said the
fight bummed me out I got sad because
being such a big expense fan realized
he's never been knocked down
I know I think I think I would say that
I think Crawford is just that good and I
think it's combination of both I think
Crawford is the best pound for pound on
the planet and Spence has those
accidents and the surgery on his eye
took a toll on him do you think that the
fight would have been different before
the accidents though oh if this fight
was three years ago yeah much more
competitive because um because he's been
known for his jab the jab just got
annihilated just got taken away again I
I wonder that then Cameron was talking
about it but they were saying his
ability a Crawford's ability to take
what was happening every time he would
throw a jab is because I obsess over
these things I love this he was taking a
tiny step to his left like a tiny step
he completely took it away it was taken
away and what it looks like Thomas
you're listening because because he
looked like he was uh is was Luke Thomas
a boxer no because to know that and see
that it's a really small detail Luke's
one of the best yeah he's very good and
when you see that and then you see how
he was make I think what bud Crawford
was doing was where he was placing his
body in his feet and it's little tiny
details was causing our boy Spence to be
off balance and he looked people have
done that and he lands and he's a
Terminator he comes forward yeah he's
never been knocked down just to seem
like it wasn't clear it wasn't even
close the fight bummed me out like and
you know boxing's great that fight
should happen three years ago and now
they're gonna do a rematch it's up to
Spence because he has to activate that
rematch clause I guess I'll watch it
again oh well yeah it's gonna happen I
want to see it probably happened at 154.
yeah if I'm butt I'm like whatever
weight you want to do just make it
competitive I don't get yeah because but
I didn't have he wasn't even sweating I
know you have a market I don't think
it's tough for me to watch Man spent if
you've ever met Spencer's such a nice
person they're both great yeah I was
talking now this is horrible stop the
fight man it's awful stop the fight I
don't think that Spence will ever have
an answer too I think a lot of times
when you're a boxer and you you fight a
guy like that you go I don't have an
answer to this and I never will
especially now yeah three years ago more
competitive fights still thinks Crawford
I've always thought Crawford beat him
even though Prime but now he did you
always you always had to buy those yeah
I know it's like no way man yeah I I've
never seen uh personally I've never seen
somebody who is that dominant Errol
Spence
get that dominated he's never been
knocked down it's crazy it was even it
wasn't competitive fight talking about
10-7 rounds I know it's just
unbelievable just bum me out yeah or
maybe or it's just that that guy is a
genius and just I think it was the
perfect one yeah he's the once in
generation Talent
Spence had you know took a few steps
back from the accidents and then it's
like this Mega fight and just happens
the biggest night of your life you're
not the same guy you know it's funny
fighting the baddest man on the planet
you say those accidents too like you
just don't know what those do to you to
you you don't know they it's in a game
of inches or even millimeters and speed
like that like
anything that throws you off at that
level it's good you don't yeah you don't
know I mean it does have an effect I'm
glad I didn't watch that and the UFC at
the same time doing companion we had
such a fun time and companion and I'm
glad they didn't have them go at the
same time that would have bum me up I'll
say this about UFC was dope I want to
hear because you didn't just watch the
whole card you'll see
well it's more exciting I I will say
this about Earl Spence having said the
fact I've actually never seen a boxer
get knocked down three times and come
back and look that dangerous still like
he had snapped to his punches he was
leaning forward like I was like damn
this guy can weather a storm his dog
he's a dog he's a dog but but a dog out
of knowledge yeah there's nothing good
stop you didn't offer anything they
should have stopped it before that you
think so yeah because I was surprised
you I figured we've been on the same
parallel thinking because like the 2014
Justin gates are like stop the fight I
can't watch this you know me I ought
some [__] oh it's Isis beheadings
whatever I'll watch horrible fights one
of the guys getting to ship it up and
I'm always like yeah that's part of the
game this was like ah stop the [__] oh
it's not his night it's not it's nice
his coaches like they're so close I'm
like what are you doing it's not the
fight I think what are these guys so I
figured you'd be on the same yeah
typically and you see him like and he
just says he's not attached to Spence
though I get it I I'm way more attached
to someone like Dustin I mean you know
but like like girl spends his smile and
he's just such a happy person I was like
in his face covered in blood you can
just tell it yeah I can just you can
feel them you were a fighter though it
was like the embarrassment you can tell
he's like you're just like oh
one of the great things about fighting
and one of the things about getting in
the ring or the Octagon is that it
you'll never understand how that guy
feels until you've been there so for you
the part of you dies because he's
because those both those men and I think
I always say this anybody who steps in
that place to get to that that level is
a thing of beauty they're beautiful
people they're so hard working it's so
difficult to do in every aspect like
that's why I can't stand when people
dismiss great athletes when they when
they make they when they talk when they
say Anthony Joshua can't box it's like
don't say that you don't know what the
[__] you're talking people are sending
like uh Dustin pore the meme of like you
gotta knock the [__] out oh my God man
even when they were making fun of cron
Gracie I don't think that's funny I
don't I have some respect for how great
he was a jiu jitsu yeah he yeah maybe
MMA right now is not a thing but he
don't don't get it twisted don't get it
twisted about how good he is
[__] off like I I understand you can you
can say hi you got beat up but start
making memes about it get out of here
that is strange bothers me yeah so are
you excited so what was your thing on
Dustin just not his Knight or no or no
this is what makes MMA better than
boxing uh-huh that could happen any
given night yep any like that's getting
caught better question is this no no
like no one no one predicted gaichi by
head kick now in hindsight looking I was
like oh my God even I was like oh why
didn't I think of this Dustin focus on
leg kick so much because that was
Justin's main tool so if I'm Trevor
Whitman who I've known forever he's my
coach he's gonna go dude all these focus
on this we're going up top of course
nines are like yes yeah so but I Dustin
won the first round he looked great I
thought Justin was good but I gave
Dustin the first round like that's a
Trilogy I'd watch them fight four or
five times I won't see that trilogy just
someone the first one they both look
good and Justin caught him all good yeah
and you see Dustin party has the
greatest reaction he goes the Watson
post fight press conference it was damn
y'all acting like it's a funeral I've
won I got a beautiful kid I've had a
beautiful career I had a beautiful wife
what are you guys doing it's all good
that's part of the job that's right
that's how you handle it now now
um talk about a storied career we'll
talk about a guy holds nothing to prove
both of them yeah
um
you know it it did he talk about
retirement no no no but but again maybe
you know again the way this game's
talked about it before yeah when he lost
uh khabibi's talk he's alluded to it
yeah I don't think there's there's not
much left for him to do if there was
like a big Mega fight something to get
him out would do it but he's a guy and
he's talking about he's like only big
fights wake me up now did you I don't
know what did you besides a Trilogy I
don't know what else you'd get up did he
did
Justin looked like he was better and
doing something different and proved me
wrong because I I I said he didn't and
did Dustin
um and did Dustin look maybe like he was
no look good I thought he beat him that
first round yeah I was checking you gave
him the first round I think the judges
did oh really didn't think it was two to
one for Dustin oh man I thought it
doesn't look good doesn't good and then
his his box on Chris I thought he's
laying in the exchanges pretty well got
caught but then yeah his hand was up too
that's the difference so everyone wants
to compare it right here yeah but it
came here yeah right here right here got
caught right it happened to anybody
anybody it's if it's not like Terence
Crawford Spence where one guy's
completely outclassed yeah I'll watch
this all day yeah yeah
let me see because I felt like that
Justin won the first round
what's it say
two judges gave it to Dustin yeah yeah I
thought he had it okay
well yeah man um good for Justin Gracie
by the way and and doesn't it look too
hurt either yeah it wasn't like flat
line like tomorrow against Leon Edwards
right did the cusp did the uh did the
submission in the first round by Kevin
Holland on kiessa surprise you no he's
been caught by a [__] DARS chokes
previously it's weird he's a black belt
too it has to be a mental thing where
you get to that position and also I was
telling you this on uh shop show the way
he shoots and his hips underneath him
he's reaching for everything I'm a I'm a
DARS connoisseur myself that's a that is
perfect picture perfect you've got his
arm out he knows yeah he's a high level
black but he knows so it has to be
something here huh then the only the
only fight on the card that wasn't but
we thought it would again in hindsight
we should have realized this because
John can wrestle but Alex Pierre Jan was
nervous news fast it was
like didn't strike with him at all like
we thought he'd like everyone thought
he'd be entertained no because he didn't
want it first round he's like nope
rushed him got him to the cage took him
down got his back he had a body lock for
four minutes oh geez but he exhausted
himself and you're at altitude so he was
tired in the second I was a little tired
Alex and him were tired in the third but
Alex won the in the exchanges because
then from then on out it was just kind
of a like a sparring match I actually
won that so Ox won the second and third
even though he got taken down late in
the third
but it was like uh Hail Mary takedown it
was like weak he didn't do anything with
it so I gave it to Alex remember I want
Alex to win because now guarantee we get
Alex bushiri next for the light
heavyweight championship is Yuri's
shoulder
he said he's gonna be good
okay so that's such a good fight it's a
good fight but but that's the fight but
it's the best fight since Jones Gus yes
but I would say that Yuri is not is
going to have some trouble with that
he's got that great karate [__] that he
does he does everything but he's just
mad chaos yes mad chaos but I'm just
good against a technical guy like really
yeah really he doesn't see he's never
seen that he's seen yawns yeah he's seen
Alex or he's seen Izzy's Chris striking
but when you get a banshee a Samurai
and he didn't caution of the wind that
[__] he's like a little Tasmanian
Devil starts getting his legs kicked
real hard good luck you don't think
people's tried that
here's a [__] dude yeah
[__] he's good at chaos dude
really he's just so awesome you have him
you have him winning I don't know yet I
haven't thought about it I just want
that fight to happen depends on how how
his shoulder is when he's come back
what's going on with him you know I hope
is he back is he is he training I I
think he's back and he shows pictures of
him training stuff can we get Tony to
retire or is Tony gonna keep fighting
Tony I I listen Tony needs one more you
got to give tony the Robbie Lawler send
off give him one more Fable match up and
then and play the highlight videos you
owe it to him can't go out on that right
there he is training right there
I thought he really [__] his shoulder
up man yeah apparently he really must
have shut up that's a big boy
three days look at him look at him
hey there's some weird stuff there
oh he does crazy [__] man he's the best
yeah well he looks a little bit like uh
the brother of that who's who's Thor
Hemsworth yeah his Chris has a brother
yeah he looks like his brother yeah
that beard is interesting
he's from where
like Czech Republic yeah Czech Republic
it's a big boy yeah him first year is
the five a year reverse Alex is the
fight
such a good fight wow
but what is his is he uh was he a K1 guy
before this no
if he tries to stand and bang with
Pierre I think that's Pierre's world oh
you gotta educate yourself on your
brother he's beat some high level
Strikers yeah I'm talking about light
heavyweight champion of the world man
yeah
and then remember yes
33 fights a lot of fights out to seven
it's a lot of fights it's a lot of
fights
that heavyweight
yeah
yeah that's that's a lot of fights yeah
yeah he's a problem
yeah he started I know he's Rising chip
was he in uh KS KSI too
kswami oh I don't see it
right yeah it's rising World chamber
which is no punk
he's seen a lot of looks you could say
he's seen a lot of looks yes yeah and
I'm sure I've fought a lot of guys who
were of the pet of the style that Alex
pierced I thought the same guy shouldn't
go down click on that bojan the blue one
the only blue name that he lost to you
fought that guy
I think so
is there a picture let me go look
I did not fight that game no that guy's
out of high altitude uh Jiu Jitsu he
fights at 170 which is weird it is 170.
yeah and and uh rumor has it he's got a
piece on him oh yeah I bet it's like a
real piece Serbia piece yeah yeah like
like uh like go back to what what did
they fight in I thought another guy
named Bogen very similar last name
what did they fight at you guys tiny
yeah
he's fighting seven he's big guy I've
seen him in person he's big kids Serbia
Balkan fighter night
I don't know what that is
oh John beat him wow
TKO Jesus Christ yeah
puts for crazy fights at 70 I mean years
of light heavyweight never goes but but
that guy bojang is a thick kid he's like
you see him it doesn't matter dude if
he's fighting at one step like Yuri did
once if I said I'll give you 50 million
dollars you're gonna make one seven
it would never happen never never he's
fought a heavyweight dude yeah he's tall
much bigger frame yeah that's insane he
beat him good for him
but yeah fights were good overall
uh are you excited for Nate Jake Paul
what's your because the word is the the
pay-per-view trending sales aren't great
right now and Nate hasn't
really been
kind of promoting it
yeah I think that Nate is has a lot of
experience as a boxer and I again though
you're talking about a guy who's really
got a lot of mileage on him and I think
Jake is training in Earnest at 26 years
old with a lot of strength and power
um and I just don't know I I there's no
doubt that I think
Nate Diaz is a better boxer right
what do you think
I think it all depends those first two
rounds like really first three rounds if
Jake can pull off something it was young
and energetic and has the power and
quickness those first three rounds if
you don't get done the first three
Nate's gonna beat the [__] on them with
his volume his tenacity his pressure
could get ugly for Jake
yeah you think so
if if you don't have a success in the
really the first second round if you're
a Jake Paul fan you'd be like oh [__]
it's gonna wear it down because he's
stay tuned keep coming and as soon as
your power even deteriorates a little
bit and keeps coming to wave are they
dragging in this you know fifth sixth
rounds can get nasty it's eight rounds
yatching and and it's ten let me just
attacked himself you know he can turn
around yeah he gets hit keeps his hands
up
um yeah he gets hit that that's where it
gets a little tricky because Nate does
get hit Jake does hit like a Mac [__]
truck well that's why it's a compelling
fight yeah chin what did do we does do
we have any idea what the Spence and
Crawford pay-per-views did I doubt it
though why is that boxer bearing her
breasts she's the only fan that's that's
only yeah
it's not even a boxer no she is she took
a fight but yeah she's like the only
fans girl she's pretty attractive
pay-per-view yeah is there any I wonder
how it did
uh let's
700 estimate 700 000.
the event surprised expectations
somewhere a thousand right get over 50
minutes it's fast they would get it
though those boys made some bang they
usually have an idea we'll never know
the real
ticket sales over 8 million in Revenue
yeah those boys are making bank oh yeah
good
700 000.
yeah I bet uh yeah Jake and Nate if that
did 700 but Jake and Nate do around 150
200. which isn't great if Nate if Jake
loses this what happens
that's the question then we'll find out
how much he wants to be a boxer yeah
because when you're making all the money
you're fighting these big names because
big names are gonna they're not coming
now he's gonna he's gonna have to fight
like you know guys yeah not big names
he's going to be the big name so we're
gonna find out if he really want some
box some Five Guys who can really yeah
or or he's smart about it he's like no
I'm gonna fight KSI fight my brother and
then dip out that's what I think if he
loses he'll fight KSI yeah he's in that
car I've gone the real route going back
to the YouTubers fights kids KSI fights
Logan Paul and probably just yeah counts
his money
uh Fury again no no no that won't happen
again no why they don't they won't give
it to him no one's gonna watch that no
one's gonna watch it
and we've already seen it doesn't make
sense yeah Furious fighting KSI next
which I think beats KSI fear is just a
YouTuber killer
good for him though it's exactly what we
should be doing 100
Hold the Line
oh Jim bring up the video perfect timing
Jay showed me this video strong one yeah
Jay showed me a video this guy hold on
let me set this up so for those of you
listen this guy's an interrogation room
with two cop two detectives two they and
he gets charged with murder and nema's
are known this farting for I don't know
two days he they charge him with burning
is what you charge me and just ripped
the biggest fart it's so long he says
excuse me twice he goes he goes excuse
me excuse me and the cop goes damn bro
I mean
because you're being in trouble right
now that's why we're bringing in here to
talk to you about it
[Music]
damn man
we'll play it again I'm gonna try not to
laugh see if you can not laugh at a fart
I don't know why not
to laugh
see it no I got charged I mean
because you're being charged with it
right now
all right
all right let me try it again no no no
try not to laugh because you're not
laugh I want to laugh can you laugh
though can you can you talk no it's a
good time but let me see if you can not
no I don't want to go why is that funny
to me
but it's so long excuse me excuse me
excuse me bro somebody got killed huh
apparently and yeah and he did
been
the best
yeah
man damn bro yes damn man also I have
your lawyer there
[__] that's funny as [__] is that funny
that's funny
it's the big ass bar bro
getting some magic mine I'll do
something I need it man I've been up
since three I'll do some magic mine do I
need a little magic today Daddy I
haven't eaten yet I like it on an empty
stomach it gives me it gives me my extra
did you like it with my coffee but I ran
out at home magic mine please send me a
package at home yeah I like what I my
favorite thing to do with this is I like
to I have my coffee and then I drink it
and I swear to God it keeps it yeah I
don't need that second cup I don't know
what it is it has something in it that
causes the caffeine I think to last
longer but also I don't get so you don't
need as much caffeine no I just feel
like kind of alert I like it when you
take these and shut your mouth
adaptogens which I love give you energy
you got nootropics you've got
matcha which I think has more
antioxidants than anything on the planet
I love this [__]
yeah I need it calm energy that's what
they call it I could use a balance of
calm and crunk well it's energized
without being jittery because if I drink
too much coffee I'm like it's impossible
for me to get jittery yeah but this
really I'll have two I'll have four
espressos two double espressos uh and
then I'm if I drink two reins yeah I'll
see Jesus do it rain and then try one of
these oh I don't want that it'll make a
huge difference because it makes it last
a long time
hmm
and it's healthy I'm excited for Austin
though buddy me too
I'm pumped guys I'm gonna take a little
break uh by the way come see me at Gap
cities this Thursday Friday Saturday San
Antonio the 24th 25th 26th at the LOL
Comedy Club I got uh Salt Lake City uh
September one and two at Wise Guys so uh
I'm gonna be hitting it hard but um let
me just talk to you a little bit about
the fact that sometimes you get in an
accident you get messed up
you know you might slip and fall at work
whatever it is these things happen and
if you're thinking about suing remember
a lot of times if you sue you're suing
the insurance company and uh and
sometimes you know you can't afford not
to Sue I'm not a big fan of suing but
sometimes you can't afford not to and if
you are in that case in that situation
you want to be able to do that quickly
and you want to be able to do it even
from your phone okay I know it sounds
crazy but this is what you can do and
let me give you some stats all right 35
of all fatal accidents occur between 6
p.m and midnight people age 24 to 12 I
mean 25 to 34 have the highest amount of
drivers involved in car crashes and
people aged 15 to 24 have the highest
rate of emergency room visits due to car
accidents of all age groups all right so
if you are ever injured you can check
out Morgan and Morgan all right
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
Morgan is so easy it's like basically
using an app
it's not even like hiring a lawyer you
can submit a claim to Morgan Morgan and
in really about eight easy steps okay
um it's probably as easy as pretending
you didn't see that 5 PM email from your
boss all right uh so so it's it's a very
very quick process
um you can do it from your phone from
your Android whatever it might be all
right
so it is the largest injury Law Firm
they have over a hundred offices
Nationwide more than 800 lawyers they've
collected over 15 billion dollars for
clients 15 billion
um so if you're ever injured you can
check out Morgan Morgan there's uh
there's fee their fee is free unless
they win uh for more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter that's
forthepeople.com
fighter and that's for f o r uh dot or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone or pound law five to nine from
your cell phone as I said anyway uh
check it out this is a paid
advertisement oh your boy James working
on my show at the Ice House crushed it
oh dude people
again I always say this he is
truly one of the funniest Comics like
you see him and he's a monster good luck
following that guy good luck
nobody wants and all his uh material
that's so original it's all about him
going through rehab it was so [__]
funny really oh dude yeah could he tell
stories the comic phone goes ah I gotta
follow Jay I'm like yeah it'd be fine no
no when's that saying saw Mike it's been
a second is not fun last week man nobody
wants he's like man nobody he's like
pissed I was like yeah calm down dude I
get it he's he's he is so painfully
funny I've seen him they're a special
you can see him when he gets up and he's
following a lineup of the best biggest
comics in the world this is the 90s or
2000s and then that dude gets up and
that dude gets up and oh my God yeah
Savage Savage back in the day it's still
seven well Sasso said that this is
coming from Will Sasso who is truly one
of the most talented people ever a
genius and will sassa said that Jay
Moore is top two most talented guys in
the world Hollywood I mean so that's
coming from Sasso who's who knows a
couple things about Talent yeah yeah he
was so funny man he's such a good time
in the green room too he says stories
for days oh I know
I know incredible I I I'm sorry I missed
his [__] stand-up that was good I'd
have one whenever he he keeps him he
always hits me up he's like let me get
another fine kid on the books
again open door policy yeah come on over
call him now
um somebody send this clip to Jay tell
him we want him on
um I'll just text him yeah yeah
um someone send this to jail
dude how about Bradley Bradley Martin
was on fight companion yeah and I talked
to Mighty Mouse because that clip of me
he did me educating Bradley and mighty
best man Mighty Mouse [__] you up 125
pounds dude I started laughing right so
my mouth saw the clip he posted it and I
was like dude Bradley's a good guy he's
like he just needs to be humbled and
he's like yeah I'm down I'll fly there
and we can grapple he's like I'm not
getting a fist fight with him he's like
I'll grab him let him know what's up and
he was like I'm going on vacation though
but when I come back let's set it up
he's gonna tell Bradley he's gonna
grapple with Bradley yeah so Mighty
Mouse he can come here how's that going
for Bradley nightmare I told Bradley
like is that true yeah nightmare why I
mean Bradley is impossibly strong yeah
there's a chance Bradley could hold him
right down not a chance
and you should be more educated because
you've actually done Jitsu you don't
think you
down to the ground
well just throw them pick them up and
throw them
yeah I don't think so Daddy but we'll
see
yeah you've seen the little baby from in
uh Incredibles yeah he gets he's are the
the what's his name uh not no that's the
baby I'm thinking of the little kid the
fast one
um
that's gonna be Mighty Mouse it's gonna
be if I was gonna go like this and my
mask and probably get him an arm bar
it'll take us rally goes to grab him
boom arm bar or he goes to his ankles
his arm bars the move with Bradley the
strongest arm in the world I think I
think Mighty Mouse is going to have his
hands full no and then he'll wear badly
I bet I bet he'd wear an aches on six
times in one round yeah no that's I'll
take that one stop over under six no no
no no no
too small yeah we'll find out
it's
it's that's a problem for probably be
fun though does Bradley want to do it oh
yeah oh really he's like I can't wait
well I would like to host that here and
we get some mats and and I will rent the
mats and I'll put them in there we'll
shoot it right here yeah cool yeah let's
do it here
fight on a kid well I think fighter and
kids should start sponsoring no I'm not
doing that calm down calm down you mean
like have fights out of here like why
not just certain certain uh matches and
certain like spectacles then we become
like YouTube like fight promoters yeah
we're the fight promoters I think it's a
good idea I don't want to be a promoter
well I'm gonna get spicy with the money
and [__] I don't worry about it with the
money and [__]
because it was because Bradley has a big
fall in the Mighty Mouse they're gonna
be like hold up you know damn it but
let's just get it out there yeah they're
down to do it here we get some mat or
they should maybe do in a cage
[Music]
I love it
just another day at the office for
Mighty Mouse
yeah what if he beat Mighty Mouse then
we just find another guy then we go up
weight class 35 45 50. I mean Bradley
Martin is not some guy he's not just
some guy no in terms of a guy like
you're talking about a man who's
stronger than really 95 of the
population and athletic and very big and
also competitive now
um so it's very different it's it's not
a it's not a little thing to tap a guy
that that big
um he doesn't have a lot of skill though
he doesn't he doesn't do Jiu Jitsu and
we know that that that if if you don't
know you're going to get caught probably
something's gonna happen there are a lot
of ways to get caught now tell Bradley's
defense he's saying no dude yeah
obviously you tapped me on stuff like
that he was before in the street he
always goes before on the street though
and he goes to do something I'm just
gonna slam into the [__] ground like
Hulk maybe so yeah maybe my mess with
his body like the reason what Mighty
Mouse the pound pound goat one of them
the least one a1b with Jon Jones is you
don't think big guys have tried to slam
before like he's seen it all dude he's
seen it all and I don't know his body
positions they don't a lot of people
don't take into account something really
important really important and and
unless you've been like boxing or any of
that is fatigue yes you you get tired so
fast you were there when I boxed
remember when I was just boxing with
that large Korean kid yeah I I didn't
know how to box I was really
and he was a lot younger and stronger
yeah and remember how tired I got
because I forgot to breathe you can't we
had we had a competitive
um
what'd you say you coward you quit
remember that and I was like well I'm
not coming back if you're gonna quit I
literally go I can't continue coward
yeah I stopped breathing can't say
coward though because it makes me angry
but that's what we call it but don't do
that now in the business we call it
coward no I stay loose I stay loose and
I can breathe but before that power I
couldn't yeah this guy what I mean I
mean he went down on the ground and put
his ass in there I can't anymore I I
gave him my ass I presented my ass yeah
so I opened my I pulled my cheeks and I
offered that but that doesn't mean I
thought you were playing possum give it
up that's called yo this is awesome I
was giving him I know oh no you're
giving up we had a competitive
triathlete come in to the gym and he put
on gloves and he wanted to move around
and he forgot to breathe because he got
nervous and he started getting just
touched a little bit and and just he
didn't last three minutes because he
just went people don't really powered
too he just fell to the he just had this
I've had enough couldn't breathe because
he forgot to breathe so he was holding
his breath he didn't realize it
fatigue makes cowards scared yeah
yeah we don't get hit
you know there you go
remember that really crazy man I
remember I was so embarrassed I was like
I don't remember that you were telling
me he's an actor
I didn't I didn't know how to box
what do you got Jen you guys notice
you're dressed alike today
like very similar
yeah your shoes almost the same color
damn sort of ammo colorful yeah just
different shoes I'm gonna do the Tough
Mudder in some famous tough mother guy
told me to buy these and then he covered
with a tough mud
common theme here buddy hey you remember
what it was it was my um newborn but
also the other reason is so you got a
new boy my calves were messed up yeah
I'm sorry oh that's right remember you
came up with the excuse that the mud you
realize what that pediatrician
said all right if you want to do that
your pediatrician Dr fauci I'm home to
your kids I was like remember I was like
well they have showers there and the
guys
yeah but the mud could track in me my
biggest concern was I couldn't I
couldn't run for more than like a
quarter mile without my calves cramping
up
it's not for everybody Bud hey bud a lot
of excuses I got good I got good wind
not running what do you got chin you
mentioned it earlier but Paul Rubens
he just passed away remember and died
that guy was the first one of the first
guys to get canceled and if I remember
right he went to a jackoff theater and
jacked off and then they snitched on him
yeah and then because he's on the kids
program they cancel him who gives [__]
what he does on his private time bring
up his allegation chin was it that sure
it's got to be on here I guarantee it's
not that'd be so [__] up but he lost
everything but if they're like he died
but also come on chin it's not gonna be
on there you're gonna have to search for
that you know big of a piece of [__] TMZ
with it because he he was a private
battle for six years he can't battle
cancer at six years oh really yeah
can you find out what kind of cancer it
was hold on at the very end of the first
bu Hermann show that show was lit those
are my favorites my kids still watch it
the original earliest 1980 stage uh okay
that's all stuff right okay go back or
OPI rallies have been held one oh long
time ago
world's uh the word sex scandal
particular a kid show host charged with
expose himself in a porno theater look
like career killer for the first order
keep going down
so he's in Florida according to the
County Sheriff's Office the three
detectives went to Triple X South Trail
Cinema okay to watch the audience that
was watching a triple bill of Catalina
5-0 tiger shark nurse Nancy and turn up
the heat with big dicks after the sting
operation sting operation don't you guys
have bigger things to do after the sting
operation that hold in Three Men on
charge the violating Florida's state
statue 800 exposure of sexual organs
will Walter really saw a man masturbate
that's how the rap she spelled it
I don't get it it was a darkened theater
it's a porno theater
according the police uh may not be Roman
attempted a buy off his off performance
children's benefit
I don't and then local reporter
recognized room's name on the rest sheet
the next day within our Scandal went
Full Throttle
so let me get so he never
he was just he was just jacking off in a
jack-off theater but there's no kids
around me you're not supposed to expose
yourself in that theater but come on man
you get one of those things you know
that's what guy's doing there I mean I
don't think you should ever get canceled
for that no no somebody I thought kids
were involved but no damn Toys R Us
removed his toys oh yeah
yeah he can't be jerking off in a movie
theater but maybe it was why as an adult
well I I agree why is it bad for me
because and and it's not like he's out
there on Instagram live like look where
I'm at kids but I think what are the
days people came to his uh defense
didn't they I don't think so he didn't
work in Hollywood for a very long time I
know that was because he was so
embarrassed but then he came back
remember he was in blow
yeah
that's all I can think about
yeah that was a bummer that one sucks
damn he had cancer
yeah can you find out what he said
please accept my apology for not going
public with what I've been facing the
last six years I've always felt a huge
amount of love and respect for my
friends fans supporters loved you all uh
I watched uh I [__] you ever see
something on YouTube with a show like a
guy on his deathbed never I I mean that
YouTube uh just came up on my feed on
Instagram it was so like this the guy
was on his Deathbed yeah and his wife
they were both young and his wife was
saying goodbye because you don't have to
hold on he goes I just want to cuddle
one that's the algorithm daddy you must
religious sometimes I was like I just
made me so sad wait could what kind of
cancer you didn't say what it is are you
okay Brett now I'm always says cancer so
maybe he just kept it private oh he had
a brain tumor oh
brain tumors six years ago surgically
removed it
so it's still unclear what kind of
cancer he's been diagnosed with most
recently that's a bummer he was great
man yeah he was childhood hero of mine
my kids still watch big top peewee yep
they don't know about those allegations
we're all gone
70s early though I think so it's only
five years from now for you bud hey man
hey that's 14 years for me it'd be cool
is it yeah bro be cool bro I'm cool
daddy you know just be cool
what else you got Jen that's a bummer he
just died today right that I just saw it
pop up today man well so this I don't
think this is a big deal but it's
popping up everywhere so cardi B threw a
microphone a fan why does this keep
happening like fans keep throwing stuff
at music artists so more updates are
coming in on this so apparently this was
in Vegas and it was really hot cardi B
had said on stage earlier like it's hot
you know throw me some water splashing
water on me or something like that but
anyways this girl oh she forgot she said
that like three minutes in the song let
me play the actual thing and then plus
the people are getting on her about the
uh Millie Vanilli stuff because she's
her vocals are playing in the background
but a lot of artists do that they have
the vocals yeah so when she threw the
mic the music she kept they kept singing
yeah
um and also she is a suspect for battery
one of the women so apparently it hit
one woman in a potentially ricocheted
off that woman hit another woman so they
don't know which one is going after
charges mics are heavy too man dude
there's like steel tops that'll hurt you
don't want to be thrown on that so this
is before I didn't know she asked
she said throw me some water don't throw
water at me
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
so here's not that one
man she sounds
[Music]
Lily's just waiting for a turn because
she was over on the right side uh stage
and they're throwing water shoes cool
with it so she's like when she gets
close I'm gonna throw some water on her
this girl's like I thought she was hot
see bam
and she actually hit her that's a good
aim Patrick Mahomes that is a good arm
also that girl threw water right at her
I was dumb right in the face yeah yeah
some people got you was digest wow
that's just a reaction you're like what
the [__] did you see would you ever see
you see what's different so with Drake
women throw their brawls and they threw
it and some girl threw a uh it's like a
36 double F and he's like man hold up
well I think we got one here he goes
security please find her an escort in
the back after the show and now she has
a deal with Playboy what yeah
really
on
this girl throwing watermelon holders
where's the one oh
locate this woman immediately
36g
he's so funny dude it's great he's great
um what about when you ever see there
was a fashion show and and Rihanna's in
the front like she's in the front like
she's watching and this girl comes out
and she looks really hot and she's just
like and she comes up to her like this
and Rihanna just goes [__] you [__]
bring that up
oh God you put Rihanna at uh fashion
show hilarious I was like upset
damn she's told her F off I was like
that's that's the real Rihanna you said
upset
flips off model there it is two years
ago watch this
did you play some of that was it who's
singing that Sade you play some Sade
I'll take my pants
she's she's a bad [__] look at her
she's beautiful
there she is
what why oh wow you're jealous Rihanna
I don't think she's jealous she's not
feeling her
Rihanna's so much better looking than
her though let's be real yeah I wonder
if she's Harry maybe there's
maybe there's some [__] that we don't
know about
uh or she's just jealous maybe she
[__] her man
ASAP Rocky
this is why she said [__] your intro
clip
on Saturday house
[Music]
okay we're still doing panel Fenty
Beauty
you see anything let's see Michelle stay
left known Wiley is the Beyonce
impersonator that got a shout out
Beyonce's homecoming documentary put on
moving performance
I started prepping for the category in
August all right
okay this is so stupid we talked to
Michelle about everything that went on
the show and it was like and what was
like to have Rihanna flip you off
because you're so beautiful
maybe why
did we get down the nitty-gritty here on
this show dude I thought he brought this
up bro all right now organic it's just
good shoes
it doesn't make sense why like there's
nothing to break down because she's just
got a little jealous listen you've heard
us talk about this but at the end of the
day let's take this guy Brian Johnson
okay he's a world epigenetic age reducer
uh macadamias are a big part of his diet
okay
um now they they have a certain rare fat
profile Omega seven fatty acid acids
which can support natural collagen
production glucose metabolism they
reduce inflammation
um they've been linked to uh longevity
and fat loss they s they they satiate
you really well okay and that's the
thing so one of the things that this guy
I'm Brian Johnson includes macadamias in
his daily diet blueprint I think that's
pretty significant because he's obsessed
with aging I also know a lot of other
people that are in the longevity that
eat macadamia nuts they're one percent
of the market they grow in very few
climates but we know somebody who has
worked with about 90 South African
farmers and their communities and their
struggling economies when you buy nuts
from House of macadamias you're actually
supporting these struggling economies
these struggling communities in South
Africa they're farmer owned all right
um and so I'll tell you I eat them
probably every day they are delicious
and uh they've got macadamia nut bars
they've got Nut Butter they've got cold
pressed extra virgin Macadamia Oil
either way we never run discounts but
House of macadamia has a very special
offer for our friends here at tfat k for
a limited time we're giving out a free
box of macadamia snack bars
okay one of each flavor when you visit
House of macadamias.com tfak
plus 20 off your entire order with code
tfak give it a shot let us know what you
think oh dismembered remains of what
hold on we got another juicy one for you
here buddy oh we're breaking down more
no no not not that I don't know what
that was we're done with that we're done
with that
that's that's stuff we're not really
interested in I don't care that'd be
more to it yeah dismembered remains a
missing crypto influencer millionaire
found in suitcase well that's not good
where was he at in somewhere in
Argentina yep yep yep and apparently
some kids found a suitcase near stream
and then they found like his parts of
his body in that suitcase that's the guy
this is the guy he was like so he had
like 900 000 followers on social media
um hold on according to the Argentine
Outlet the Manhattan mystery crypto
million named Fernando they were
followed with violence that the man
promised to kill him in a gruesome way
including cutting his eyes out and
chopping off his hands I'm going to kill
you I'm going to do something worse to
you I'm going to kill you I'm going to
do something worse to you okay in a
voicemail message uh it didn't make
sense I'm going to gouge your eyes out
and cut off your hand so you can't have
any more money in your life I swear on
my children that have no problem going
to jail
another one he put you betrayed me and
you caught me I have poison with you
that I hate you
so they're not threatening you I'm
telling you that I'm gonna rip your head
off the money is mine you don't play
with mine okay yeah so they're accusing
him of taking or stealing money and then
there's also I really did it I think
it's that guy yeah I would imagine it's
that guy yes who told you he's gonna do
that and that's exactly what he did
that's the guy huh that's the guy that
was dismembered yeah
but apparently he didn't really have
that much money and he was he had
failing businesses so there's a lot of
it with show and I think that's that's
Instagram in a nutshell I came on top of
that for all how did he where was he
so he was uh he lived in Buenos
what the [__] he was living somewhere
else but then was in uh Argentina for a
little bit and that's when he when he
was supposed to he was renting a place
and you never returned the keys and
that's how they found out that he was
gone he was 24. damn they just cut them
all up yeah so they were able to detect
who it was because you know specific
tattoos and bad bees all that crap
is he wrapped up I think they're able to
tell who it was by his face what uh he
had wrapped up irreverable debts and he
was also
they said that he might have been
affiliated with some sort of like you
know gang and they wanted money from him
he wouldn't give money to them so who
knows yeah it's some cartel [__] where
they cut you up like that that's not
good
yeah
yikes was he a
H I think these are just like IG
pictures
just to show off again okay well
anywho that's cool symbol there
well he's a young man uh who is this
we're in some dark arts man
oh another person that passed away
Sinead O'Connor yeah she passed away as
well was her suicide no they said
nothing faulty or nothing like you know
suspicious well that doesn't mean it's
not suicide son died that Center off the
edge suspicious doesn't mean to that
means that that means that she was at
murder too yeah but because this was
just gonna be also suicide no I think it
was suicide it's not they won't report
that they usually let the family or
somebody else do when they say we don't
we found no like uh evidence of like
killing right now she suffered from
terrible depression yeah I remember I
talked about committing suicide yeah and
she was gonna do it before yeah and then
something happened but yeah it's
terrible my age
yeah nothing no details on the death
yeah I think she other than nothing
suspicious her podcast her son died her
son died and she was like I don't know
how I'm gonna go on like I want to join
you horrible oh yeah yeah she had some
slappers though yeah she had yeah and
she was the first person to expose the
Poke yeah with sexual abuse I remember
being like she's everybody's like that
that kind of killed her nobody would
[__] with her no pun intended you right
nobody would [__] with her after that
but she it was on to something because
she knew better she knew people had been
abused I think she'd been abused by the
clergy so she was like remember when
she's saying Conor McGregor's walkout
song I mean probably the greatest
walkout and you see here dude nuts it
was great that's a bummer man yeah she
was so talented and you know uh uh
Morrissey when she died everybody's all
the music Executives all the people like
I loved her and he was like where were
you guys when she was going through her
[__] you weren't anywhere you would
smile on it and you didn't they're glad
that she was so talented you wouldn't
touch her and now they're like oh
tribute to you like shut the [__] up
yeah right well it's a little bit like
your boy who went bad on people who
after Bonner died everybody said ah poor
Bonner it's like where were you when he
was yeah I was like where was this yeah
what's Sean Strickland said that you
know it's like yeah I'm a struggling
with that yep
Michelle O'Connor though that's the
bummer she may have been going through a
lot of stuff she looks a lot better at
56 than I did or I do
did you know three people a month jump
off Golden Gate Bridge well that's why
they put those those uh Nets down there
that crazy yeah that doesn't stop it
does nah man still three a month still
yeah the Nets just hold them under
longer now don't they get caught in the
net no no no because boats have to go
through there now would you read that
stat read it Jen damn there's not much
they can do there's that documentary
called the bridge if you want to do it
it's the number one place America to off
yourself if you want to do it
if you want to stop it why not I mean
taxpayers money but I mean San Francisco
do something with the taxpayers money
can't they have security at the bridge
I don't know like going in and out
eighteen thousand eighteen hundred
people
only 35 is survived fatality rate is 98
and that's from hitting the water yeah
yeah those who do survive strike the
water feet first and at a slight ankle
whoa
a wasteful 400 million Golden Gate
Bridge oh they've tried
hold up that says of the recorded 48 000
suicide record in 2021.
no but that's that's total suicides
it's not from the golden game
they account for less than one tenth of
one percent of the total yeah so so a
lot 1800 think about that that's a lot
I couldn't believe how many because from
the bridge that documentary I was like
there's so many people it's like three a
year six a year oh I get that stat from
it was my favorite new uh True Crime
podcast called going west because there
was this kid who suffers he's bipolar
and they have video of him uh going up
to pulling up to like the base of the
bridge and then a bus pulls up and then
they don't see him anymore but his
family and friends thought he just
jumped off the bridge so then they have
video everywhere for the bridge you know
to confirm if people jump or not and
there's a splash like on the back side
that they weren't expecting so this
kid's been missing since he's like 21
he's been missing for like 10 years and
they've never found his body they don't
know if he got on the bus or left but
there's a splash behind and on there
they said uh two or two or three people
a month commit suicide at Golden Gate
Bridge that's why I got that stat yep
really it's not the way to do it I don't
know oh it's doing it the right way at
all but I feel like that's a real scary
man it's pretty high up that's a jump
it's right here the only thing not
involving deaths is happier right yeah
well this is my sister sent me this this
is Alicia Keys son questioning her
attire for the night and I was just
wondering if you guys thought this was a
good son or you know just an
understandable situation cute kid
super cute kid
so everybody can see your boobs they
can't they just see a heart I've never
seen somebody do that well you're only
eight the worst is going to be of this
okay how about we do this
how does he do this you do the topics
like it's funny
[Music]
I don't have a problem with it no it's
great and she was like the worst thing
you can see is this it's like a little
underboom I mean hey I'm also Alicia
Keys little [__] I'll like keep you
that's what I do keep kids keep you
grounded
I love it
um so this uh
these are reports I don't know if this
is 100 true or not but this is a fighter
from the UFC who's very poor and I guess
he had that same story like the rock
where he had only 700 or 700 seven
dollars or something yeah the first UFC
fight they'd send the money back home to
like build water wells and [__] I don't
know Africa but apparently Dwayne Dwayne
was Dwayne was moved by it so much that
he visited him in Miami and apparently
he bought him a fully furnished house
which it's just reports I don't know if
it's 100 true that's dope oh that's
pretty cool
yeah
that's pretty pretty just done heads
done guys like can you give me a truck
50. no sponsored
that's cool though shelter The Rock do
you guys remember this kid
from Love Actually
oh yes he married he just got or he just
got engaged to Elon musk's ex-wife what
he said he was such a cute kid I
remember this guy
he's done a lot of stuff yeah he did a
bunch of stuff that's Elon musk's
ex-wife yeah she's very cute how old is
she 37 how old is he
let me see him though
a lot of stuff yeah but I'm thinking of
one thing go upstairs they had it right
there remember Maze Runner click on all
of them is there more if you click on it
yeah oh no he's from Game of Thrones
that's what I'm thinking Game of Thrones
you know what
yes he is Brandon yeah good call yeah
because I just finished it
again for the fourth time third time
fourth time
forgot about that he's good in that too
he's a good actor really good actor who
is she he gets murdered she's also an
actress she is yeah or she bring her up
because she looks pretty does he have
his money
does she have any of his money
um
I mean she's
cute she looks really good there too
Westworld oh boy season two oh she's
gorgeous
I never got into Westworld did you guys
I'm into her
I can't take that much but I won't take
it down
he just looks like a kid all the time
right she looks like his mom yeah she
looks like his mom yeah this is awkward
she looks like his mom they're not it's
a weird couple Mommy good for them
she's [__] beautiful
I'm sure oh yeah she's pretty he's got
that hair huh
he does and she um she has a good amount
of elon's money too elon's got a head
huh he's a big dude and he's a big brain
dude to Mars or not how about the
confirmation of aliens coming
all right
that guy's a whistleblower though and
they went to Congress what do you so
you're talking why does that guy do that
so I talked to uh uh Congressman about
that oh God and uh well I don't trust
that guy but yeah well no he goes uh I
said what's going on he goes what's
going on I think he's full of [__] I go
why he goes because you can get up
because it's not a lie you can actually
you can lie you can get up and lie and
there's no it's you're you're exercising
your First Amendment right so people get
up in front of Congress and lie all the
time and tell fantastic stories this guy
is telling an amazing story do you know
why because he's gonna write a book and
it's fantastic marketing that's the best
marketing it's the best marketing you're
testifying in in front of Congress that
you saw uh you saw aliens they've been
here since the 30s alien craft yeah and
I don't like to use the word aliens
let's say non-human uh-huh yeah and
where would we where would we look well
I can't say that I can't say I can't say
I can't say and I call complete and
total you don't believe it but do you
believe in aliens
I don't know I don't think that uh
they've I don't believe in Indiana I
don't think the US government is keeping
it a secret from us no yeah I don't
think they're I think they would oh I
don't at all but I think a lot of it I
think a lot of it could be listen I
believe in aliens 100 I think it's
insane not to believe in aliens or
non-humans well but I think it's more
likely
these people aren't aware of the
technology that America has or tried it
has and these drones so when you know
those F-16 Pilots that you see they
don't have the clearance so like we've
never seen this thing look how fast it
goes exactly and the people that know
the government's like oh [__] exactly
you don't have the clearance correct so
yeah it's a UFO buddy yeah you've never
seen that I do I think we have such high
level advancement like the drones flying
saucers what the hell we're using and
those people flying the planes the
people that see it don't have the Clans
yeah but our government knows what's
going on I agree I do think they've seen
aliens out of communication with them
though uh you do yeah uh I know they
haven't but that's okay what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean you
know hey I'm not saying Tripoli but no
but they haven't
how do you know well how would you know
well I I wouldn't I would either I
wouldn't no but odds are on my side
they're not on your side yes they're not
no life form and you think we're the
only I think we have there's other life
form in the universe I've never made any
contact I think any human being
certainly no certainly I don't think we
have first of all if we have zero
evidence if we have made uh zero
evidence if we have made contact with
alien life form we're not keeping that a
secret we'd know about it do you think
the government's transparent everything
they do they just can't keep a secret
not not something that big JFK they kept
secret pretty long here well there are a
lot of people that disagree with that
conspiracy theory is the only thing
right but what but let's say it is
conspiracy there let's say they were
involved in killing it and kept that a
secret
yeah maybe I don't know what other
secrets that it seems like everything
the US government tries to keep a secret
is always exposed right it's like
eventually I mean I mean it's hard to
keep a secret I mean that hard it really
some of the Hillary Clinton stuff this
Biden thing like what about Hillary
Clinton
you know she's associated with 50 people
that have died at her level but it's
also complete what's 50 like 70s a
little higher no and it's one guy was
killed in plane crash you know that
means it's not true like no no 100 there
are so many people right so of course
you're gonna know 70 people do you know
50 people that died do you know 20. I'm
associated with people who've died
if you were if you were 75 years old and
you knew and met as many people as they
have in government 50 people that worked
with you or that had communication no to
the people who died well she's the only
one in the government they're killing
people I don't know what's going on I
have no idea I don't know it's alarming
to me there's no I go that's weird
there's no one and I mean no one who
actually is somebody who's taken
seriously as a scholar historian
journalist or somebody who writes books
or knows the clintons well there's no
one who cooperates that correct of
course not there's no one but why would
they because people think they're going
to write a legitimate truth what you had
was one guy who had a website with a
bunch of horseshit I'm sorry but every
time I I but how many scholars have
written books about Biden and his his
dealings in Hunter biting what about
Hunter buddies
now we do but it comes out is what I'm
saying the idea that the clients are
committing murder no no or responsible I
don't think Bill and Hillary are doing
it themselves they have a hit team I
don't know I don't know but you do know
no I I do think they're shady as all get
out nobody disagrees with them the fact
that the clintons are shady they're
they're slush fund which was their
Clinton Foundation the the rape
allegations on Bill Whitewater the the
rape allegations on on Bill all that
that's been that's been in that's been
in the news you know and been out since
he was before he was president there's
no what is Governor right who's accused
of rape yes all of that so we know all
that they swept they took care of all
that I'm saying I'm not saying that
these are great people I'm saying that
in in Washington there are a couple
things going on first of all getting
away with murder is a pretty risky thing
but also here's the the other thing
about Washington you don't have to
murder anybody you can kill them other
ways for sure right and that's what I'm
saying is I I don't think uh these I
think it's a little idiot to think that
nobody in government could get away with
murder
yeah it's a different skill set though
right it's like um I think that it's
it's there's so many people watching
every move you make and you have so many
political enemies the clintons have a
lot of political enemies that's right
that's to try to get away though right
that's right
not a diet but people die yeah and when
you when you have connections with
people you can draw connections for sure
so John of God he just got uh indicted
he was going away for 99 years he was a
Brazilian guy who used to heal people he
was a rapist a serial rapist Oprah
Winfrey went there once
and she he was healing people and she's
kind of hokey and she was like God his
presence was so powerful and he said a
prayer over me okay and she went she
went off she's one of those people who
just like it seems like a really Wild
guy and she's a she's an Entertainer
and then all this stuff is like she was
connected to this guy no she wasn't at
all
she went there
did a thing on him and left that is a
connection you can draw connections so
so which so then what about Epstein
Island and the book they won't release
so you think all that's a coincidence I
think all those people I think the most
probable thing about Epstein was that he
was probably working for an intelligence
agency probably Mossad probably the
Israelis yeah but what about all the
celebrities and politicians that went to
the island multiple times that was well
known and documented yes and the
government won't release the name so so
a couple things about that one is I
think those were powerful people men
especially were trying to get laid and
they were getting laid out there now
some of them might have been with girls
who were 17 who knows what I was no we
know that he was there 14 year olds who
knows
so I think for example um let's let's
take Epstein it's a good one people say
he was killed in that jail cell okay so
the first suicide attempt which was I
guess didn't happen was was that a
suicide attempt or they try to kill him
and they didn't get away with it the
second one was if if it was the Mossad
or these professionals who can get into
a jail and they can they're that good at
controlling the cameras the lights and
everything if they're that good and they
get away without a trip they were done
before they would have done it way
before way before he was if they had
access but you you don't have more
access when he was in his home in in
West Palm Beach than they would have in
a jail cell but you don't think you just
think it's just coincidence the camera
wasn't on that he was a suicide risk and
just all of it you guys took a break all
of its coincidence yes because I don't
believe in coin because I think it was
especially when it comes to the
government if I was Jeff Epstein I would
have killed myself because he has no
and he also knew he was guilty I mean
he's a bad guy of course so so I think
someone like Jeffrey Epstein all the
people associated with Clinton's the
clintons multiple times Clinton's all
that stuff oh they're all Bill Gates all
of those guys were there and they were
and you know they're all doing bad [__]
that people they're all just [__] is
what they were doing underage girls well
what I think also happened was the the
uh Mossad
and stuff they I'm guaranteed they had
that place videotaped and they had they
had dirt on all these people if you
think it's a massage you don't think
that's conspiracy theory in itself so
you believe he's the reason I think it's
more plausible with Epstein was because
we don't know where he got his money
from we don't know like he lived in that
mansion that he bought from Wexler for a
dollar or something there's all this
stuff where where it's like wait what
was he doing
he's part of the massages money that
close to the Clinton sure well he's that
close to everybody ah I mean he had a
picture of Bill Clinton but the idea for
the Mossad or whoever it was who said
the way you compromise powerful men and
you get you know you get that's all
Epsilon made it
these chickens don't be part of Assad
but for Epstein that's how he made his
living yeah so you get these guys out
there and it's like this is in his
living room I don't think it's as sexy
as people want to make it I think it
makes I think even if let's say you
don't believe that he's involved with I
don't know the massage stuff it's pretty
sexy I mean the the stories yeah an
island oh yeah you have Bill Gates
multiple celebrities
royalty oh yeah that you so you don't
believe in you I think that's pretty
sexy no matter at all that all went on
100 yeah yeah I'm saying that that was
all a Honey Trap right I think that was
a Honey Trap I think part of it was that
sometimes you'd have people over there
celebrities they'd all have a blast he
was the man and then other times they
got dark yeah they got they got
information on people if they need
information if they need influence they
could go hey dude now that's thesis and
also the pedophile stuff sure well I
think Jeff Epstein was into young girls
he was known as the guy it's one thing
to be into so is Bill Clinton 18 and 19
year olds it's another thing to be into
14 and 15 year olds and the reason I
believe that is because the air traffic
control people in those Towers said he
was coming off that plane with girls
that were very young yeah and that so so
we oh look we're in international waters
legal legal that's what was going on and
those girls didn't have ID they weren't
telling people what they were that girl
who was with prince Andrew no don't you
think it's weird we don't have they
won't release the names in the book in
the black book I do so do you think that
eventually comes out just so you know so
that prince Andrew okay that 17 year old
girl you know they came to his lawyers
first and asked for 26 million dollars
and and the mistake prince Andrew made
was saying no I'm not going to give you
that because they were like we'll make
this go away
we got we know that this girl was 17 we
got a picture now we're going to
embarrass that's not a problem though
give us 26 million dollars
and they went all right here we go and
that's why he's [__] he was done and
his lawyers will tell you his lawyers
will be like hey that [__]
should have paid that money pay up and
keep him getting one month Queen of
England here's what I think you know I
think I think a lot of these really
powerful people that were on that list I
think there's been a lot of money
exchanged I think there's been a lot of
hush money paid a lot and the and the
people that saw Alyssa said there's
current politicians that have been in
the island several times that are
currently working sure and if it gets
out it would compromise them so what
they've done is so so so here's what you
know that's where do they'll be no
here's what I think there are girls that
are coming out and speak I was such an
age I was here okay those guys know
exactly what's going on
and their teams know exactly what's
going on they thought they were safe I
will promise you and I know I know this
that those girls those girls and their
team their teams they come they go to
those guys and their teams way before
any of us hear about it for sure and
they go hey we need 30 million that's it
and and all those guys go they saw what
happened to prince Andrew but no but
it's illegal so the government should
release this isn't that weird they don't
release the names it would be they
released the log but none of those women
what a surprise that none of those were
but we don't need that we're traffic we
don't need those but we don't need them
we do no the government can release the
names not the women of the people on the
island they already did there's that
list remember that list that came out
not the not the flight log that we have
the flight log that's whatever yeah
we're talking about we're talking about
Epstein's black book
the doj doesn't won't do that unless
they have a case you don't have a case
with our witness you don't have a case
without a victim you don't have a case
without somebody who's willing to say I
was trafficked and I think yeah oh [__]
yeah they're all making money I think
they're panicking I think they're taking
care of each other I think they're all
scumbags at the top and they're just
protecting each other they can't get it
the way they're doing that I don't even
think they're talking to each other I
think what's happening is that again
because there's Republicans on there's
Democrats on those girls they're all
helping each other those girls have
lawyers yeah those lawyers are smart and
those lawyers look at the girl and they
go listen we're gonna you're gonna make
30 million dollars out of this or you
can go after them and nothing's gonna
happen no that's right he's Untouchable
that's right prince Andrew you can go
after him and punish him and he'll get
embarrassed and go away further career
or you can get 30 minutes or he'll just
live off his money yeah you're talking
about very rich people the richest the
Bill Gates Bill Gates the classic
example I will guarantee and I happen to
know a couple things stay settled that
that the man that the man made it go
away these people make things go away
and all it has to do is you get uh some
lawyers who sniff around and go hey hey
and he goes I know you know I got you
and that's what I think really went on I
don't believe in uh coincidence
that maybe with that stuff yeah but it's
always I think it's money I buy I by
accident no uh I know of two of these
instances because I happen to know these
lawyers by accident and it's really
interesting and you're like oh because I
I was the same way yeah and may I I did
some poking around yep and it made total
sense I was like why am I so dumb why am
I so naive yeah it's like hey bro these
are these women now are a little older
and they're smart and they and more
importantly yeah but more importantly
there are there are people who are you
even smarter like if your wife came your
wife is Young if she came to you and was
like hey B
I was on Epstein Island Bill Gates and
Bill Clinton ran a train them you'd be
like wait what she's like do I come out
or my Laura said I could get 50 million
dollars I'd go well I'd go get your
money let's let's let's buy some
expensive champagne and pop it because
because we won the lottery we're about
to move into a nice house with a great
feeling we won the lottery yeah okay are
you okay yeah we only see a therapist
yeah we get the best therapist 50 mil
yeah well
um how do I do this uh I have
yeah okay well I would say were you on
Epstein Island no I've had experience I
had I have I had a person I was uh with
who uh
well I could have done that to somebody
very very wealthy and very famous and
didn't
and uh and then not not not her style
but yeah you can do that stuff oh you
can do that stuff if you want yeah if
you asked you and I get a rap here
that's it
all right kids uh me and Cal will be in
Austin uh calling us to Austin at cap
cities this Thursday Friday Saturday I
will probably be at the shows on Friday
then Saturday night going down
jregan Eddie Bravo myself fight campaign
for koi sandhagen Rob font that is going
down this Saturday on Joe Rogan Spotify
you can watch live on YouTube that's at
8pm central time and then next Friday
I'm in Phoenix Arizona one night only
two shows August 11th stand up live then
Omaha Nebraska August 16th Kansas City
Missouri August 17th get Joe tickets at
thickboy.com
cap cities LOL San Antonio August 24 25
26 uh come get some it's gonna be good
then a Wise Guys Salt Lake City coming
at you September one and two ooh baby
all right kids love you